take a look at who just not to rub the
outdoors with all the Oscar nominee used
to dandelion seeds mom that's how we
roll at et it was an incredible day now
every year they get together at a
special luncheon to say Oscar for one
epic photo the 89th academy awards
nominee is class of 2006 I was talking
to one person I said well you know this
is my seventh it was actually eighth
with the picture the guy next to me says
my 21st
that would be sound mixer and in Elson
21 noms and two wins in total it was 167
nominees
right next to Oscar super casual in
sweatshirt jeans was second time nominee
Pharrell Williams looking around I'm
just excited to just be a part of it
Octavia wasn't far from me Natalie
Portman it was pretty cool
Natalie do very soon with her second
child was given a seat right in front
next to Octavia emma stone and matt
damon
across from Matt's it's original song
nominee Justin Timberlake in the back
Ryan Gosling had his arms crossed in
front of him
lion co-stars Nicole Kidman and Dev
Patel were smiling side by side next to
director nominee Mel Gibson Michelle
Williams peeks around Casey Affleck
while her Manchester by the sea co-star
Lucas hedges is a little star-struck
standing next to lala land director
Damien Chazelle when we stepped off
after I just like came up to him I was
like look man I just wanted to let you
know I'm so grateful that we touching
elbows made me really emotional do you
ever get starstruck underneath oh I
remember years ago I met Jimmy Stewart
yeah I was the guy healed man Sidney
Poitier when I met him when I was a kid
except for the underdressed pharrell
cocktail Sheik
mostly rural like Emma Stone Stella
McCartney jumpsuit Nichole's knee-length
Chanel and Naomi Harris's embroidered
vertigo Vanetta dress come ask your time
all these nominees will be stepping up
their game
what used to get out of his Oscar outfit
like me Denzel I was with you backstage
after you're a SAG Award win and
wondering how did you how did you
celebrate with Paul out of it we all my
short-sword
because sports every young you go hit
the streets and do all the man I went
home get out of that monkey suit
[Music]
you